Thank You mr. chairman
my name is sock puppet I was the
pets.com mascot from 1998 to 2000 by a
show of hands how many people remember
me Hey
let the record show no hands went up
okay well a decade ago I was bigger than
Kung Fu Panda
I had a float in the Macy's Day Parade
and a commercial during Super Bowl 34
but in just seven months my company
stock fell from $11 to 19 cents we
became so illiquid that I couldn't use a
fire item for three weeks yeah I don't
quite understand what the hell you just
told me you know cuz Doug's be in fire
hydrants there are facilities you need
oh thanks mr. chairman I don't really
have to go now but let me get back to
why I'm here
the dot-com crash sank a whole lot of
companies Webvan boo calm and yes pets
calm but you know what it's not the
fault of the taxpayer I understand sir
but my point is why are you talking
about bailing out the auto companies
when you let all US tech companies just
crash and burn I mean I lost everything
had to sleep on Jerry Yang's couch for
five years if you're a plumber well mr.
chairman Frank's sir
the thing is I could get back on my feet
if you could just float me enough money
to make another Super Bowl commercial
hey would you have an act during the
Super Bowl this year
well actually the Super Bowl will be
February 1st of next year but that's
just around the corner that's why I need
money quick actually a bunch of money so
pets.com can you know come back to life
and survive can you just tell me in
absolute terms how much money do you
need to survive okay 25 billion how did
you reach the 25 billion figure for this
particular request
well first off buying ad time during the
Super Bowl is expensive three million
dollars per 30 seconds yeah but that's
just the beginning
I went Tom Brady to be in it and Gisele
Bundchen they're dating you know the
hearing is now but wait do I get my bail
out the witnesses are excused think of
all the bad related
Erbs wear sock puppets bailout what goes
up must come down spinning wheels round
and round